[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
it was a outdoor walking park with
descriptions of each president on sign
boards the park was spotless
very nice place for the family and
stroll your little babies around in
their strollers pretty neat it wasn't in
the best location so it failed through
the recession and the park was finally
closed its sat dormant for probably two
years or so and a new developer came in
they asked if I could come and remove
the statues they were putting a new
business and car business instead of
going to the crusher I brought them up
to the farm and there they are their new
home I looked at the statues and said
you know I think I can pick these things
up and move they are 20 22 feet tall
they weigh about eighteen to twenty-two
thousand pounds we probably spent close
to fifty thousand and moving the
Presidents down here over about a three
week period took about six men
ten hours a day the presidents are
pretty isolated even my neighbors are
aware of their existence back here the
weeds have grown up around them shorts
Naik's and alligators are all little
frogs they love them the unusual part of
visiting presidents Park would be
standing close to these enormous heads
you almost feel they're looking at you
the way they're the sculpture did the
work on them it's it's an overwhelming
feeling to be next to these giants of
men who represented our country and
built this strong country we live in
[Music]
when Obama was elected the funds weren't
available to purchase him
and the original investors they said
they've done enough they they did get in
a bomb ahead you know it's a small one
couple got dropped I think Lincoln fell
over backward and unfortunately broke
the back was head out it's kind of
ironic that that happened there's a lot
of interesting facts about the
presidents that many people don't know
Thomas Jefferson he found at the
University of Virginia James Buchanan
was the only president not to marry
Warren Harding he lost the White House
China set in a game of poker
I believe Martin Van Buren's
was the first person to use the phrase
okay it was said that James Garfield
could write a sentence with his left
hand in Latin and a sentence with his
right hand in Greek at the very same
time
whoever Cleveland had to have his jaw
removed because of cancer and they
replaced it with rubber
ulysses s grant got a speeding ticket on
a horse Andrew Jackson had taught his
parent how to swear and they had to
remove it from his funeral to keep it
from swearing meant a lot to me to
preserve history and to be able to pass
something like that on I mean I loved to
find the means to build an educational
park for our kids to come to from all
over the country I really want to do
something with these guys I mean they
this cannot be their fate sitting in
this field and being crushed
I do crush concrete and I don't want to
do that if I have to leave them here
it would really disappoint but you know
there's been a lot of effort put into
saving them
I could use employed or some help maybe
[Music]
[Music]